hi I'm Captain America how many more of
these hey everybody this is going to be my
thor ragnarok post credit scene video
there's going to be a whole bunch of stuff
dropping this weekend between this and
infinity war so be sure to subscribe to
get everything and I'm still doing the
Thor ticket giveaway I'll explain at the
end of the video so there are two post
credits scenes unlike guardians of the
galaxy which had like a bunch of extra
things tagged onto the end of it
especially that music video that they
shot special of the two Thor scenes the
first one is all about the mythology
Infinity Ward stuff is coming next
that's pretty standard for Marvel phase
3 film soap bars like the mid-credits
scene the first one you see will be like
the next big thing that's coming and
then the one that plays after the
credits like the true post credits scene
is mostly just a funny moment with
characters from the film in the mid
credit scene you have Thor Loki Heimdall
coorg Valkyrie pretty much everybody
that survived Hellas final assault on a
spaceship going to create a new Asgard
on earth like they did in the comics
Asgard existed as a city on planet earth
for a little while until they rebuilt it
back in outer space but all of a sudden
a giant ship jumps into frame in front
of them preventing them from moving
forward it looks like something
reminiscent of the shatori technology
but it's pretty clear they're implying
that this is Thanos his ship his ship in
the comics is a little more bulky
looking but because he's been using the
shatori as his infantry this whole time
it makes sense that his technology would
flow from that so the idea is that
Thanos has come to collect the space gem
but Loki has stolen it he ports away we
actually got a shot of him in that
comic-con infinity war footage with the
tesseract on planet Earth so we know
that Loki basically Jets out before
Thanos can take it from him because
infinity war is going to be a heist
movie in the story as Thanos taking the
gems from the Avengers but because the
very beginning of the infinity war
trailer is Thor face-planting on the
Milano it's implied that Thanos blows
that Asgardian ship up and he just left
floating through outer space we don't
know why the guardians go to Asgardian
space but they do wind up there somehow
so that just teases that that's the
first gem that Thanos is coming for and
before the movie came out I thought he
might be coming for that particular
gauntlet but because it's implied that
the gauntlet that he puts on during age
of Ultron is the real gauntlet in hella
says that the gauntlet in Odin's vault
is totally fake it just seems like he's
coming for the space gem first it is
sort of an easter egg for the first
movies because the space gem is the very
first infinity gem that we saw in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the mind gem
was the one after that so even though we
haven't seen the soul gem I'm expecting
some Easter eggs in the logic of how he
goes after the gems like oh these are
where the gems popped up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe during phase 1 phase
2 so for those of you asking about the
aether I'll do an infinity gems video
later this weekend too
but what happened is is the aether was
given to the collector so at some point
in Infinity Ward there will probably be
a scene with the collector getting his
ass handed to him and Thanos taking that
gem the planet Asgard is effectively
destroyed by a Serdar after he's sort of
resurrected in the eternal flame like
they chuck his head in it's meant to be
kind of a funny moment in the end of
doing their version of the Walt Simonson
Surtur saga so he haven't read that it's
actually a really cool comic book story
but like hella says you're not powerful
enough to defeat me and they're like yet
we're not but he is so they sort of sick
Serdar on hella and you think that she
might be dead but because she's such a
big cosmic entity and because of all the
circumstances surrounding who she is a
Cate Blanchet being such a great actress
in such a high watermark for actors in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe it feels
like they'll try to keep her around and
because she literally refers to herself
as death at every turn every time she's
on screen it just sounds like they'll
try to turn her into the cosmic death of
the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet saga so as
far as we know there is no hella an
infinity war like that's right around
the corner we're going to be watching that
in May so I would assume for now that as
of the end of the movie she's not dead
she's like Loki after the first Thor
film just floating in outer space until
he eventually makes his way to Thanos
who gives him the mind gem with the idea
that he can take over the planet keep
earth while Thanos gets the gems but
think about it this way if Thor can
survive in the vacuum of space
until he lands on the wind she
of the Milano then soak in hella if
Hellas supposed to be more powerful than
Thor based on the way they explain each
other in the movies even though they
both had this godlike power she's just a
little more terrifying than he is but
again they have not confirmed anything
if she comes back it won't be till
Avengers for which they are filming
right now and currently they're actually
filming something that looks like it's
going to be a flashback scene to the end
of the first Avengers film because
they're all wearing their old costumes
Thor has long hair again Loki's wearing
that muzzle that he had at the end of
the first Avengers film so we'll talk a
little bit more about that this weekend
the second post-credits scene is all
about what happens to the Grandmaster
after the end of the events of the film
this is big revolution on Sekar he tries
to pawn it off like he's one of the
people and he inspired them to do it so
basically it's just a full-blown revolt
it's implied that he's dead but because
he's an elder of the universe he's
incredibly powerful so if you remember
the funny team Thor videos they did just
a parody what Thor was doing during
civil war they said that they're
actually going to do Team Thor part 3 and
it'll be the Grandmaster that goes to
live with Daryl so it'll be Jeff
Goldblum and Daryl doing the team Thor
thing but the way they talked about it
made it sound like it's only going to be
released with the Thor Ragnarok DVD so
we probably won't see that for a couple
more months but Kevin Feige was hopeful
that at some point in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we would see the
collector in the Grand Master share a
scene together but they do heavily imply
that the Grandmaster is killed by his
subjects at the very end of that
post-credit scene so for all intents and
purposes it seems like he's dead even
though he shouldn't be given his power
levels but what'll happen is is I'll
post my Easter Egg video on Saturday
just to get people a chance to see the
movie I know it's been out for a couple
days internationally but it was just
released in the United States as I'm
posting this video so let me know in the
comments what did you think of the
post-credits scenes compared to say like
spider-man homecoming which also had a
sort of tag that wasn't quite what you
expected like they had the Captain
America patients line where everyone's
like wait a minute I waited around for
this are they trolling me what is going
on that sort of Marvel's new strategy is
like okay well give you a little teaser
for the next movie that's coming up but
then we're going to Troll just a little
bit but I know a lot of you are
wondering when
infinity war trailer is going to drop
there's nothing official that they've
said about that but just be prepared for
it to come before the end of the year my
expectation now is sometime in the next
six weeks or so I think if they're going to
release it before the end of the year
it'll be sometime between now and when
star wars comes out in the middle of
December what'll happen is is all
announced the next giveaway winner when I post that next Marvel video you can
click here to learn all about Odin's
Infinity Gauntlet and you can click here
for my review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!